在心理学里边
它是一种与生俱来的特质
我说过拥有这种特质的人
大脑在处理外部信息的时候
她会更加的细腻
她会更加的敏锐
对环境的变化呀
对吧
他人的情绪啊
包括这种潜在的风险和机会
都有着比常人更强的这种
和这种
换句话说
就是
他们的这种
比普通人要密集的多
也更容易被激活
从某种意义上来讲
就是这种神经系统的高反应性
就像一台高配置的精密仪器
就是你能够看到常人看不到的细节
理解常人理解不了的复杂情绪
然而这种高配置
却不一定能够自动的转换成为
对不对
你看事实上
很多高敏感的人
在现实生活中
她常常陷入到一种矛盾
就是思维很敏捷
洞察力又强
但是在金钱和职场
他总是觉得显得格格不入
他们并非不聪明
恰恰相反
很多高敏感的人
智商极高
而且想象力丰富
视角独特
能够站在更高的抽象的层面
去理解问题
但正因为这种思维方式的跳跃
不落俗套
那我告诉你
你在这种常规的这种工作体系里边
反而容易被误解为
想太多或者说你不接地气嘛
特别是那些出生在
在资源贫乏
或者是环境不友善的家庭
或者社会底层的高敏感的人
就是他们的不同
常常无法被理解
也难以被接纳
哪怕你说出去的是对的
很多时候没有人愿意听对不对
你即使遇见了这种风险
或者是这种机会
也没有资源
支持你去实践
所以你看
久而久之
很多高敏感的人
他容易被否定
容易被嘲笑
陷入深深的自我怀疑和内耗
他会觉得
是不是我太敏感了
是不是我太奇怪了
那我告诉你
这种心理的路径
就容易演变成为
甚至是
那么这也是高敏感人群在心理咨询当中
频繁出现的一些隐性的痛点
就是他们往往比别人
更早的意识到问题的存在
却因为缺乏力量
和这种平台去解决
所以他觉得很无力
那么
高敏感的人
该如何走出
困境呢？
那如果我说答案的话
只有一句话
把
转化成为
就是你自始至终
你的这种输出的路径
你要换一个路径了
你看在现在社会的结构里边
其实高敏感的人最适合发展的
不是这种机械的重复的这种劳动岗位
这种真的不适合高敏感的人
你需要的岗位是什么？
第一个
第二个叫
第三个叫
第四个叫
结合这四个词
创意共情洞察和表达的
职业
比如说哎
和艺术有关的
心理咨询
还有写作
或者是科研
也或者是教育
也或者是自媒体
那高敏感就成了这些领域的
大家理解吗？
是
而这些正是高敏感人的天赋所在
所以
一个高敏感者
他真正的修行不是
而是反倒你要学会理解自己
在你的自我成长中
重新建立内在的秩序
与自我的这种价值
逐渐走向影响力的表达
你比方说你可以打造属于自己的IP
传播自己的观点
你自己的经验和这些专业的见解
让世界能够看见你
那么在这个过程里边
你不仅可以疗愈自己
也更能够以真实的经验去帮到别人
也让你自己的影响力
具备了变现的可能
大家理解吗？
你看很多我们熟知的
一些顶尖的心理咨询师
包括一些作家
包括一些老师
包括一些自媒体的创作者
他本身就是
也包括我呀
就是你通过输出这种价值
你构建了一个属于自己的影响力
也赢得了经济自由
和一种尊重
所以真正的财富
它是源于内在价值被认可
所以高敏感的人
如果能够走出压抑
与自我否定的这么一个循环
通过打造属于自己的平台
去连接这个世界
我告诉你
他就会具备了天然的
因为你的这种敏锐
你的诚实
你的深度
其实正是很多人在迷茫时代里边
渴望的所谓的
当你的表达方式越来越成熟
我告诉你
你的这种影响力也会随之的扩大
可能
从最初的几十位观众
对吧
到成千上万
到数十万百万的粉丝
我告诉你
这条路或许并不快
但它是真正适合高敏感人的一个通道
到那个时候
你不需要去讨好谁
也不需要硬融入于那些
让你不舒服的圈子
而是凭借真实的价值
自然聚集来与你同一个频率的人
我告诉你这个时候
你的社交圈
就会逐渐的升级
你会链接到更高级的认知资源
和这种合作的机会
那你的变现能力
也会随之提升啊
是不是
那最后我想告诉大家
高敏感它不是一种
而是稀缺的
它不是
而是
你不是太脆弱
而是对这个世界
太用心了
所以请相信
你的价值正在被需要啊
只要你不放弃自我表达
和内在成长的修行
我告诉你
这三个东西终将
会属于你